crazy dude
pure evil that's how the county sheriff
described 18-year-old payton gendron the
gunman came to a buffalo new york
supermarket in a predominantly black
neighborhood with an assault rifle
wearing tactical gear and a camera to
live stream his actions
this was pure evil
it was straight up racially motivated
hate crime from somebody outside of our
community outside of the city of good
neighbors as the mayor said coming into
our community
and trying to
inflict that evil upon us
11 of the 13 shooting victims were
african-american a retired police
officer tried to stop the assailant but
was killed before buffalo police arrived
at the scene and surrounded the gunman
forcing him to surrender the governor
was quick to react
and it is my sincere hope
that this individual
this white supremacist
who just perpetrated a hate crime on an
innocent community
will spend the rest of his days behind
bars
and heaven help him
in the next world as well
a newly released report from the centers
for disease control says that gun
related deaths in the united states
reached an all-time high during the
pandemic in 2020 that includes suicides
and gun related homicides which
increased by 35 percent
those numbers remained elevated in 2021
and show no signs of abating we will not
stop until every lead is investigated
every piece of evidence is analyzed
gendron will appear in court on thursday
to face first degree murder charges and
if convicted the possibility of life
behind bars
kristin salumi al jazeera new york